Okay, we are recording and it is the 20th of June I think in 2018 and this Zoom calls going to be an understanding histamine as we start to go through everybody's genetics.
This is one piece that we go through and it's one piece that we go through a little bit more adept because histamine can be a feeder of cancer.
So just to go over this again, so we're all on the same page. I also want to remind you that when we're getting results back like results back on your genetics or results back on your IVG test.
I have put presentations together for the IVG. You'll have to go to the website and you'll have to click on the resources tab, which is on the top of the website next to the store.
tab on our website and on the resources tab, you'll see all our blog posts to IVG information on how to understand what the IVG score means and such is on a blog post so search down. There's a search bar on our blog, though, so you can search for IVG and you'll come up with that, but you can scroll down and you'll see that.
Also, when we go through your genetics, I don't want to go through the test widely. I mean, I want you guys to know what we're looking at. It'll be helpful for you to understand.
So when we go through genetics, it is absolutely required that you watch some of the genetic videos. If you click on the genetics tab, the genes leave clues, I think is the tab name.
It will on the bottom of that tab, you'll see some other links to genetic pages and now the cancer genes book, which is a video book.
On a written book, it's a video book is up on our website on the bottom of that genes lead leave clues tab, you'll see cancer genes, the book. You can click on it. The book is a living book made it's constantly being added to, I only have done the first three sections of it.
The multiple multiple sections as time goes by, so because of the adding videos, the amount of time lapsed in the videos that are out there right now are multiple hours of videos. I know that you're not undergoing your care here, nor are you looking to get a PhD in functional medicine and genetics.
However, the learning as much as you can can be very helpful. So at least watch some of those videos before we go over your genetics. So you really understand what we're even looking at. It doesn't just all look great to you.
So some of you want to dirt out more, some of you don't usually the ones who want to dirt out more are on these calls. So we're going to just dirt out a little bit of histamine today.
So histamine is important. So we hear about histamine because we see television commercials about anti histamines. And if you have a stuffy nose and runny nose seasonal allergies can sleep, take an anti histamine and it will decrease the histamines in your body so that you'll be able to breathe fully and get rid of seasonal allergies.
So does that true? Well, it certainly can be. The problem with taking a drug anti histamine is it will reduce histamines, but then you get a reflux secretion of more histamine and it's really not solving the problem.
So even though I'm not against using anti histamines at different times, if you have a long-standing histamine problem, we want to address the reason that it's there and not just become dependent on anti histamines that can have all sorts of other side effects that we are going to get into here.
So histamine, what is it? What does it do? It's secreted in the body and it does numerous different things. It's the biggest thing we think about histamine with histamine problems is the immune system because histamine acts as a vasodilator. So it increases the dilation of the vessels and allows your immune response to attack substance.
So what does your immune system do? Your immune system kills things that are invading your body like a virus or a bacteria or a fungus or a mold, some living organism, a biotoxid is what your immune system is supposed to attack.
However, when things get into our body that are not supposed to be in our body, let's say we eat a food substance that gets across a damaged gut border and that food substance was supposed to be too big to get across a healthy gut.
But because we have a damaged gut border that food substance gets across in our immune system fires a reaction we end up with histamine means accreted by these cells called mass cells in order to bring a more immediate immune response there.
So histamine serves a purpose to aid the immune system.
Well, that's a good thing. But the problem is is that your immune system is only supposed to fire against biotoxins living organisms and what it's firing against things like foods or allergens that we are absorbing that we shouldn't be getting into the bloodstream in the first place.
We have this immune response to things that aren't even killable.
So histamine continues to be up-regulated, it continues to be secreted by the body because of the fact that these things aren't being killed by the immune system.
So an example would be my damage got allows larger particles of proteins across its membrane into the bloodstream and my immune system sees that as an enemy tries to kill it and because it's just a peptide or a part of a protein, it doesn't die.
So it's constantly ramped up and you got this constant histamine reaction where it's continually being secreted in a healthy individual with a healthy gut that doesn't take place, but when we have a damaged gut, this is what takes place.
Histamine serves other purposes too. In the stomach, it stimulates production of hydrochloric acid for the preparation of digestion of carbohydrates.
In the brain, it functions actually as a neurotransmitter and regulates sleep and actually helps you get up its memory formation and brain arousal.
So it's similar to glutamate in the brain, it's an excitatory neurotransmitter. That's why an anti-histamine can help you fall asleep, it makes you drowsy because histamine is a stimulant in your brain similar to glutamate.
So there are stimulatory and there are down-regulatory neurotransmitters in the brain, histamine is a stimulatory neurotransmitter.
Mass cells, I already mentioned, are what secret histamine in the presence of the deed for histamine, which works on a negative feedback loop in the brain, in the stomach, it's secreted during a mastication.
So you chew it up food, that's your, your catalytic is released in your mouth and that stimulates the mass cell secretion in your stomach.
Well, we always think of histamine as a bad guy, but you gotta think of it as a good guy too.
So don't think of anything in your body really, that's created in your body as always a bad guy.
It's all about balance, remember.
So life is about balance, it's about having that right amount of something in your body at every time and it is literally that out of balanceness that we have that causes disease.
And then we have to look at so, okay, is histamine the bad guy we're going to take it into histamine, well that might not be the right thing to do, at least at first we need to look at what is causing this imbalance that is causing the excess histamine in my life, that's what we want to look at.
So a couple of reasons where that might be I started down the pathway to explain one of them, it's an immune response and one might say it's a baritone immune response, the immune system is overactive, that's the problem, well it's really not it's really a correctly active immune response.
The problem is is that your immune system is firing against enemies that are killable so going back to our example of a damaged got causing peptides of proteins to get through that never should have gotten through so we got these these things in our bloodstream that are not broken down completely.
Our immune system is supposed to fire against enemies so it sees that as an enemy and it's firing against that enemy that's not an apparent response that's not an overactive response that's a normal response what's abnormal is the damage to gut wall allow this thing to get through that never should have gotten through.
So all we're going to do is decrease my histamine response when we decrease our histamine response we're decreasing our immune response so should a cancer patient take an anti histamine drug no but once in a while it's fighting it should anybody take it you know once in a while it's fine but you got to look at the reason why it's there.
We don't want a chronic immune response because that's not going to be good for a cancer patient we want a good strong immune response not this this light up regulated immune response that isn't really stimulating T cell production to kill cancer cells and that's what high histamine levels will do over time so that's why it's important to look for the cause so.
Is there an increased immune response meeting just that chronic slightly up regulated immune response increased histamine levels that histamine itself histamine is not a killer so histamine is not killing bad guys histamines.
Purpose in an immune response is to increase fluid to the area in vasodilate and by vasodilated the cells to increase the flow of immune system cells to the area the problem with cancer is that I said some cancers can then use histamine as a fuel source so we don't want a.
Chronic inflammation so that's what will be produced in this is a chronic inflammation that is simply up regulated histamine and and not really giving you a T cell spike that you want to kill cancer cells so we have to look at what's causing this and that's where we get back to gut function of using that as an example because that is so common.
But now there can be other reasons to a person can have chronic biotoxins think I'm going to slide on this i'm getting better by slides here but maybe I don't so chronic biotoxins like a chronic lime or a chronic empty bar or a chronic viral infection that is just this this slight insidious response that is stimulated histamine flow can be an issue that we need to deal with that too so.
Damaged borders gut border lug border blood blood brain barrier borders could cause this.
Chronic infections could cause this chronic toxicities can cause this that slight chronic ramped up immune response so these are the things that we want to look at and these are things that can be then causes for cancer and all sorts of diseases.
Dietary sources of histamine can be an issue those are usually not so much the issue we're going to talk about when they are but there's histamines that are contained in foods so we're not talking about dietary.
Food allergy that's causing a histamine response here because that will cause it to but we're talking about foods that contain a lot of histamine cheese eggs nuts fermented foods alcohol aged foods kombucha things like that are high in histamine and when we look at your genetics that will look at it just a little bit that's what we're looking for whether a person should be eating those or not and we'll talk about that.
So trying to gain that balance how do we do it's really understood to understand that when we talk about histamine what are the things that are stimulating that histamine response remember it's not so much that we're told we're trying to get rid of histamine it's about that you it's a good way to think about it is that you have a bucket and you create you know you create histamine through your body.
Through different sources and you get it in your foods through all sorts of things more than than are on this list and if that bucket is filled up and it overflows that's what we're out of balance and it causes problems though that bucket is never supposed to overflow because you have a fail safe method in your genetics.
So you have a way to get rid of histamine so just like anything else in your body you have these metabolic pathways you create a substance that has a purpose like histamine it's great purpose as a neurotransmitter as helping create hydrochloric acid in your stomach as vasodilation to get an immune response to tissues.
All these wonderful purposes but then you have these genes that help get rid of it the HNMT gene maybe the more important of these there's a this is a number of genes in this family are the genes that created enzyme so remember what are genes do most genes are the purposes to create an enzyme and that enzyme that acts on the local tissue or on a distant tissue and that's how it has its function.
The HNMT gene and the ABP1 family of genes create the enzyme called DAO that DAO enzyme is what breaks down histamine so when we look at your genes we're looking at this right here actually there's a little bit more than these but I just took this little snippet out.
So the ABP1 genes if the person remember if we look at genes like this person has no defect on this ABP1 gene that on this one they have a single olio defect on the HNMT genes this person is pretty toast because they have a 2 2 2 2 out of these genes they have a number of homogenous or double olio defects of these genes meaning that that the gene is not going to work at all but it's not going to work quite as well as if you did not have a defect.
So this particular individual with genes like this they have a more difficult time making the DAO enzyme in the tissue therefore they'll have a more difficult time clearing histamine from the tissue the ABP1 gene is responsible for making the DAO enzyme mostly mainly in the gut.
So digesting the histamines in that they're consuming this person a 1 and a 1 probably doesn't have much problem with the tummy ache after they eat kombucha or a high histamine meal but they might have problems with airborne allergies might have problems with rashes if they get a mosquito bite they tend to react a little bit more they tend to have more.
Or quote unquote allergic type responses maybe more stuffy noses kind of thing because of these defects of the HNMT gene they don't make the DAO enzyme very well in the tissue so that's how we look at the genes when we are looking at the histamine genes we also look at other genes like the FUT2 genes because this is really important for God help.
Because again you have to go back to the why do they have this purpose purpose this problem their symptoms in the first place you got to look you got to continue to look deeper it's not solely a genetic issue of the of the what clears the histamine but it can be what's causing the ramp up in the first place.
So you got to look at leaky got issues that we discussed all these different things can increase chronic histamine levels so that's what you're going to look at for causes now what do you do to look at for actually try to take care of this well.
Going back to well number one you got to heal the gut you know that's why on everybody's on everybody's laptop you got that video that you watched when you were here about healing the gut so healing the gut is most important reducing inflammation and find out what's causing the inflammation do I have another food sensitivity do I have a damage got because of chemical toxicity.
There's just enormous amount of different possibilities there that we want to dig into reduce histamine foods especially mainly if you have those ABP1 defects though this person I would necessarily reduce any histamine foods but if the person did have a lot of ABP1 defects we would say that maybe histamine foods are not going to be your friend and we need to reduce these right here.
And then using some pre and probiotics that's why we put just about everybody on sunscreen because I have not really met a cancer patient that has had maybe not choose throughout their FUT2s but a lot of FUT2G defects and the FUT2G is primarily responsible for healing the gut and creating butarate and fueling the gut cell regeneration and that's exactly what's in the sun.
And that's why we put just about everybody on sunscreen to help do that using digestive enzymes helping HCL production helping break down carbohydrates helping break down proteins supporting liver function supporting phase 2.5 all these things that we want to do that we are doing on very many of you and ultimately it's for the purpose of reducing systemic inflammation it's just this chronic and city is inflammation that causes issues.
It's the heart of most diseases today so that's what we want to look at what are some other things that are causing it this is some things that are touched about different infections H-Pyloride, Lyme disease, molds, parasites and certainly toxicities you can even if you're eating all organic get away from toxic exposure.
So that's why we use some different products to reduce these things this is the DAO enzyme itself it doesn't get absorbed but it helps with the breakdown of histamine in the gut especially if you have ABP1 defects.
And it products like histamine scavenger, curcumin, boswellia, anti-inflammatory products are very beneficial and the best stress reduction head kit is just to beg your head against the wall that's what I use but that's the idea of looking what fills the bucket how do we deal with that one of the causes why the bucket is overflowing
and to me that's the best way that you could really personalize medicine.
So hopefully that was a good quick overview and I didn't go too fast I'm going to unmute everybody I do want to get to one question that somebody had so before I open it up to questions I'm going to mute you again sorry.
Somebody had a question on Facebook I think or they maybe they emailed it in that they told there I had mentioned multiple times that the majority of your chemotherapy so if a person is doing chemotherapy the majority of the killing of the kids are is done within the first 48 hours and then you want to work at try to pull off the chemotherapy.
And someone actually asked their oncologist is that true of the color said no I don't believe so I think it's constantly doing that and I do agree that with the oncologist in the sense that yeah I do think that if you have a poison in your body there is going to be more killing of the cancer you know if you just leave the poison of the body but I think I will stick to my guns with that the majority of the killing of the cancer is done in the first 48 hours after administration of the chemotherapy.
And after that you still may get some killing of the cancer but you get much more destruction of healthy tissue and so I'm still that's just my opinion you could decide what you want to do with my opinion is this and after 48 hours you really should try to start pulling out that chemotherapy pulling out that toxin.
Now remember what is chemotherapy a drug that just goes right to the cancer and kills cancer only in our dreams so chemotherapy is is going to just kill cells if chemotherapy works on the process of cell lysis and you're hoping that it's going to be up taken by the cancer cells because they're hungrier.
So and it is so chemotherapy is going to be up taken by the cancer cells much more than it's going to be up taken by healthy cells because cancer cells are hungry I mean literally they are feeding more so that's the benefit of our chemotherapy approach if you're doing chemotherapy of fasting prior to chemotherapy.
Your other cells are more stable they're healthy they can handle a fast chemotherapy are starving and they are excuse me your cancer cells are starving and they want to they they need to feed so they're going to just gobble up the chemotherapy as soon as they're fed anything.
Especially after a 24 hour fast so we've gotten some really good feedback on our chemotherapy approach and how it's decreased people symptoms so continue to do that.
Now I will open it up to questions but before I do someone just texted or chatted a question is grounded inhibited by wearing shoes versus barefoot good question so i'm going to open it up and I will talk about that so I'm going to need it.
If you go outside with shoes on you are not grounded yourself so it doesn't make a difference if you have even leather shoes on versus rubber souls unless you're unless you have enough wetness of your you're wearing literally wore out boxes that they're soaked with with wetness so that when you're touching the ground.
You are getting some electrical conduction there anything other than that if you're walking outside in Birkenstocks you're not grounded yourself there's too much interference there there's not going to be electrical transfer of ions between you and the Grove unless you're barefoot okay any other questions.
There was another question with that one will sunscreen black vitamin D.
The sunscreen block vitamin D that's a good question I think the answer is that is yes and no so there's you're still going to get some production of vitamin D while you're wearing sunscreen but I do think that there is some blockage and if you that's why if you do Google that I think you're going to get mixed reviews on that.
So I personally I'm not a fan of sunscreen but I'm also not a fan of getting burned so does the sun cause cancer the answer is yes and no so if you allow your skin to get burned over and over you what a bird is is you're you're damaging cells you're causing cell lysis you're causing pathological cell death.
And if you're going to continue to cause pathological cell death over and over you're going to increase your risk for cancer that's the problem with problem with radiation radiation is causing pathological cell death and you're increasing your risk for cancer.
So it is with the sun burns if you just go out in the sun and you're not allowing yourself to be burned you're not increasing your risk for cancer better fact you're decreasing your risk for cancer the sun is good for you it's allowing yourself to be burned that's bad for you.
So if you have skin that burns really easy i'm still not in favor of sunscreen if you're going to wear sunscreen you should make your own or buy some natural sunscreen without the chemicals in it.
However, you could you need to cover yourself up with a hat cover yourself up with long sleeves where different types of clothing that will keep you cool but keep you from the sun.
Well i'm not getting the vitamin D well it is that's true but if you burn that easy then you're going to have to go out in shady days where you're not going to get direct sunlight and not get burned.
I have skin where I think it's partly because i'm kind of trade by skin a little bit if that's if that's proper terminology.
I'd I'd ever wear sunscreen, but if I somewhere in the winter from Minnesota go down to Florida i'm careful that I don't burn myself i just wear it hats are covered by self up.
Dr. Connors this is Mike and Donald March and saw we had a question.
Uh-huh.
Does the time restricted eating i guess it's a two part question when you drink something in the morning does that does that upset the t re schedule.
It depends on what the what's your drinking so if you're going to drink just water with some limited or something like that no.
If you're drinking there's even there's even so there's there's studies on this so how do you how do you know that it's interrupting the time that you restricted eating protocol is does it raise or the easiest way that you can do is if you have a glucometer at home.
A way to measure your glucose through a figure figure prick if it doesn't raise your glucose it's probably not interrupting your time restricted eating so there's argument whether even black coffee will do that in the truth is is that some people could drink black coffee and it doesn't raise their glucose will not even any sugar in my coffee.
You know, it will it can still raise your glucose because it will break down ultimately into glucose so if.
And then other people make a drink by coffee and it doesn't so it the best way to know is if you have a glucometer.
You measure your glucose in the morning and let's say it's 87 and then you drink you know a cup of tea your favorite tea that you really like in the morning and you measure your glucose 20 minutes after drinking your tea and it's still at 88 or something that you're fine but if it bounced up to 102 then I can't have that tea.
Very good the second part of that question was on time restricted diet.
We have some friends that are on a keto diet and they said that it raises alkalinity and it can also cause some kidney issues I just wondered if you could comment on that please.
So if you're on a full ketogenic diet where you're trying to totally get into a ketogenic state which by definition is is that you are burning ketones for energy instead of glucose for energy yes it can put some stress on your kidneys.
However, currently we don't have anybody on a full ketogenic diet.
Now do not confuse because ketogenic diet is really fad like right now so don't confuse a ketogenic diet with an adkins diet so people often are on about saying this friends but there's a lot of people that are on say they're on a ketogenic diet but it's just an excuse to eat a whole lot of meat and bacon.
And it is that can be very stressful on your kidneys so that's not what we're advocating no so make sure we get that straight at a time restricted eating diet that's not going to increase stress on your kidneys at all especially if you are drinking continuing to drink water.
Ms. Donna drinks a lot of water and she is we are trying the and using the time restricted diet that you recommended will she be losing weight with this time restricted diet.
It depends so I'd suggest that if you know everybody's so different with this but it comes part of it is steps from what your body has been used to.
So for me to go out of time restricted diet personally it's like I already do that before the even called the thing a time restricted diet because I never ate breakfast and I never ate lunch of eating even since I was in high school that just is how I operated so it's.
To me it was like well this is too easy other people that are like used to eating breakfast at a stack and lunch at a stack and dinner and that's been their life you know up to this point then you're going to have to make your window a little larger.
So instead of you know shooting for a 6 to 7 hour window you might have to go to a 10 hour window to begin with and slowly work down to whatever your goal is.
Very good thank you.
Thank you.
Yes absolutely.
Who is a good candidate for a ketogenic diet what kind of people would should be doing.
I think surfers.
Sorry.
So from a cancer perspective so from a non cancer perspective we just talked about this in the clinic should everybody be doing a ketogenic diet in this world the answer is we have to take a step back first to find that so that is a big
bad right now but I'll tell you probably 95% of the people that are doing a ketogenic diet are not in ketosis.
A true ketogenic diet is you're getting your body in ketosis leading your birdie ketones as opposed to glucose because you don't have any available glucose to burn.
Is that the right thing to do for people in the average no we were created to burn glucose through glycolysis into the Krebs cycle to make ATP.
I don't think a ketogenic diet I think a ketogenic diet should be used for the right reasons.
Maybe the right reason to use a ketogenic diet to help people lose weight that have had very big difficulty losing weight people that are diabetic ketogenic diet would be a good choice for them they need help working through that especially if they're at insulin such like that type two diabetics perfect choice for a type two diabetics.
Certain cancer patients depended upon go back and watch in the cancer gene videos the different types of cancer if the if the patient has high LDH levels and I don't want to get it to explain it all what that is but LDH is an enzyme that's created by a gene called the LDH that is supposed that the purpose of that is it converts pyruvate.
It's pyruvate to lactic acid so people with high LDH levels that you could measure that out of blood test are converting that quite readily and that's not healthy because you'll end up with a lot of lactic acid which will be a fuel source for cancer.
Two, if they have a gene called the pdh gene which is supposed to convert pyruvate into acetyl coenzyme A if you have defects of that gene or if you have defects of the hif what a gene that to me from a genetic standpoint and from a lab standpoint is a sign that we need to go on a more keto like diet but I use that terminology keto like because
Get a person into true ketosis is difficult you really have to go on a three to a really almost a five day water complete water fast to get into ketosis it's not easy.
Some people especially if you are a little bit overweight might even have to go on a longer water fast to get into ketosis.
And then to stay in ketosis you it's difficult and I know a lot of people that are on ketogenic diets are using keto sticks which are urinary test sticks to measure ketones accretion it if you're secreting ketones in your urine all great haven't ketosis well that's been proven to be false you will spill ketones in your urine blog before you are really in ketosis you have to measure blood ketone levels.
So it's harder to get into ketosis and to stay any ketosis that is often believed so the really most people are out of keto like diet and I'm not knocking that we just need to define our terms a keto like diet is really appropriate for most people if they're trying to accomplish what they're trying to accomplish which is trying to.
Burn more calories or more efficiently decrease a fuel source for cancer really you don't need to get it to full ketosis you need to get to a keto like diet so you're really strongly decreasing that fuel source so
The my piece of that is number one we test people with kinesiology you measure all the age levels you look at pdh of the gene and a defects and h i f one defects plus defects in the caros genes and the any one genes so there's there's multiple pathways that you look at that will suggest that a cancer is being fed through lactic acid thereby it's being fed by.
By primarily by glucose so hopefully you could follow what I just said there.
So if you don't eat breakfast or lunch ones of first time do drink anything i mean when's the first time you actually put anything you know are you included alcohol.
So I don't always not eat breakfast or lunch so sometimes if i'm home during the weekend i'll eat breakfast but it's just been personally my habit since I was in high school because I didn't have a mom plus or so that made us lunches you know she said you guys make your own lunches make your own breakfast and.
I just did wasn't good at doing that so it's I just took classes that I just did take a lunch in high school and I just and so that was just became my habit so my habit became I just I just not hungry in the morning and if I stay busy I just don't think about I don't get hungry and then I consume 17,000 calories when I get home so that's not good.
So my fat my time restricted eating had to concentrate not so much on the time that I'm restricted but the amount of calories that I was consuming during that by feeding time so.
um yeah I drink water and now I'm trying to get a little bit better at drinking my green drink and such during the day what I'm here and my staff tells to remind me of that they're a blessing to me that way so.
So you're not promoting skipping breakfast and lunch no but I am promoting that it could be extremely helpful to do time restricted eating.
Now it doesn't have to be a breakfast and lunch that you skip it's whatever time of feeding time that is best for you to be it's would be a lot harder for me to eat breakfast and lunch and to not eat when I get home it's the easy part is well I can easily fast for for 16 hours by.
But time I go to bed at night and wake up in the morning and I will eat till I get home while I'm past 16 hours already so that's a real simple thing for me to do other people really like breakfast and their breakfast people and it's easy for them to skip dinner so everybody's a little bit different that way it's just whatever you pick your window.
Yeah I have to take medication with me every 12 hours so I have the ball sky can I do this 12 hours yeah that's okay too so that's just everybody's got to pick whatever it's going to work for them.
Dr. Carr, this is step sports not to change the subject but go back to detox um I'm are you familiar with Sophia Health Institute.
No.
Okay I think they're out of Washington anyway Kristina Schofner or Dr. Klinghard.
Uh huh.
Are those people?
Yeah but I'm familiar with it.
Okay it's from those people um they were in conjunction with an Italian doctor and I'm sorry I don't know his last name but his first name is Marco.
So anyway it's a researcher and he said this is nothing new but it's they found out the function of this the interstitial fluid that we have it's he said it was made up of a lot of tubules that helped detox the body and that um they use is um what do they control it and fall fate.
Uh huh.
Yeah.
That's your body and it's just recently discovered by him and other researchers that it's made up as numerous tubules and they drained the lymph fluids and um and they the fluid around your organs.
Are you familiar with any of that?
I am actually that's a little bit of how you've heard of GCM a F.
No.
So GCM a F is a it's got a okay so that is a macrophage activating factor that got a lot of press a number of years ago as a cancer cure.
Um it was produced by a company in a great Britain that has since been shut down by the FDA of England um because they if it's not patentable because it's a natural substance.
Okay.
Um there's you can google GCM a F and there's a bunch of information on it now you can't get it anywhere.
So um we were determined to create our own GCM a F like substance and um we're actually just in the process of doing that and it's one of the main constitutes of it is controlled.
And the thought process is is that could right helps get the product to the cell through the extra cellular spaces.
So your your cells are are tightly packed right in your body and you have spaces in between your cells.
So we talk a lot about cell membranes and we talk a lot about live drainage well what does your live braid.
So your live is drained this what is being thrown into the spaces between the cells.
That's called your extra cellular space however it's really not a just a space.
It's a matrix of proteins and tubules and waste products and garbage and and and nutrients.
So uh your your capillaries release nutrients into the extra cellular spaces and then those nutrients and chemicals.
Uh go through the cell attached to cell receptor sites stimulate cell function you know and we said before that it's really the the skin of the cell or the cell membrane that is the brain of the cell because that is really what's controlling everything that's going on of the cell because it's that's how the cell interacts with its environment and the environment of the cell.
Of the cell is the blue that the cell is rested in which is the extra cellular fluid.
So as the cell does things which habilizes things and then the spit sits waste back through its membrane into the extra cellular space if your extra cellular space is not able to drain that away.
Then we're going to have problems we have waste sitting in the extra cellular spaces.
And then nutrients can't get to the cells and things that you're trying to if that cell is a cancer cell multiple cancer cells.
How are we going to get the good stuff to that cancer cells to kill it as well right.
So we don't want chronic ramped up inflammation like what we spoke about in today's little talk that is going to just gum up the whole works.
So you're the health of the live system is very important that I've likened the live system to an open ended capillary system which is kind of like a storm sewer.
And if you could take the to be the extra cellular spaces as like the streets and the streets that they don't have storm sores and you have raid well it's just going to flood everything.
So he was he was also talking about how to get rid of all that you were talking about this.
Well, you can your skin is a source of detoxification but you're not going to get rid of something that's in the middle of your belly of the skin you still need to use your live system.
The skin is going to get rid of things that are closer to it.
And proximity and using that's where could right it and glucose and we said are good anti inflammatory how do they work they help kind of pave those roads.
So, but you still need a good detox pathway that's where using sawdust you're you're basically bypassing the live system but you're not going to get the deep things using a soda.
Use it a foot bath you're helping bypass the live system so you're trying to use as many detox pathways as you can when you're getting rid of joke out of your body.
Okay, are you familiar with ultrasound therapy because I've never heard that one either.
So ultrasound therapy is just another way to use ultrasonic waves to move exudatory move fluid through the tissue.
So we used to use ultrasound all the time of you move the ultrasound around and it's setting these ultrasonic waves in there and while you're moving the head of the ultrasound it's just pushing fluid so it's just moving fluid moving it around.
So ultrasound used to be used in chiropractic offices and physical therapy clinics like everywhere and then that it sure it's not paid for it and also the all these machines appeared so it's unfortunate because it's a good live moving system.
So that's what they were just trying to move the limp.
Well, you're moving you're just getting getting the extra cellular fluid moving.
Ultimately, you try to get it to the lift if the person's doing sawdust you're trying to get it to through the skin you're trying to get rid of it.
Okay, going back to histamine all your capillaries histamine does it not and playing the ends of your capillaries and decrease the exchange of all those nutrients to your organs and stuff.
Well, histamine is is vasodilating.
So it's going to increase the leakyness of your capillaries.
So it's going to make your capillaries more leaky and that's what the purpose is it wants to get more fluid there to bring more more immune cells to kill an infection.
So that's not necessarily a bad thing it's just when you have hyper histamine levels that that becomes a bad thing.
That would him and Geomas are he medgeomas he medgeomas have to do the breakage of capillaries so partly but you're getting more red blood cells spilling in a he medgeoma.
So that's even a greater amount of leakage yes.
So that's like for me, my major thing was histamine so that's what's happening with the histamine is compounded.
So there's other things that that also cause capillary fragility versus just capillary dilation.
All right, thank you.
Absolutely.
All right, we're going to have to wrap up today because we are way over our time.
So thank you very much.
This will be up on Facebook in a little bit and we will see you guys all next week.
Thank you.
Oh, you bet.
Bye.